okay this is a candy crush saga level 18
walk-through tutorial video
it goes along with our guide and uh
shows you how to use the tips i'm going
to play through the level and see what
see if i can't complete it and explain
my decisions as i go
so the key is
to use these coloring candies as best
you can
to
clear out as much space and ice as you
can um you know it's one of those levels
you kind of got introduced to the idea
in level 13
where you know there's too much ice to
get just by making matches and we're
going to start out by just taking out
some of the um licorice
and we're going to
try to make some special candies in the
process
so
we could if we match this here it's
going to turn all the red into purple
that's not particularly awesome
so
i'm gonna wait and see what else i can
come up with
the reason this level is so hard is
because um the dark blue are in play
and then so we have seven different
colors and when you have seven colors it
makes it a lot harder to
make special candies so
you will run into spots where you
really can't do what you would want to
do
so you sort of have to roll with it
now there are a lot of purple and
there's quite a few purple specials um
now if i match a purple color bone with
the purple it's going to
it's going to change one of the other
colors so i'm going to go ahead and do
that and see what happens
let me change the greens for us so now
we have a ton of purple on the board
and that's
usually a pretty good thing um
it's not ideal here
well i guess it sort of is
i was gonna say you know you want to
have two colors but when you have this
much purple i guess making those all in
the stripes will be pretty good
and i'm not even gonna i could do like
i could try to get fancy and
you know fire off some of the stripes i
already have
but we're going to need moves later so
i'm just going to go ahead and do that
right now
and that's going to clear out most of
the board
all right so now we just have to get the
last three bears we can see all of them
and we just have to um
can you know it sounds silly but we
actually have to conserve our 25 moves
um this doesn't look bad at all we don't
have any double layers left or anything
but
if you played this level before you
probably
had one of those attempts where you just
knew for sure you were going to finish
and then ended up doing another move so
you should always pay attention
it's you know
it's a little bit insidious like that
it'll just
really just won't be able to get that
one square for some reason another thing
that's working our advantage here is
that we
we only have one
um
we only have one
uh ice
piece of ice up there that's not in one
of the matches we want to make so our
fish will actually
work for us here
but the um
you know like like in our guide you know
the key is is to uh make the right
decisions when you get a good board and
you know
you really have to capitalize when you
get a chance to make the big matches or
the big combos you know because
you won't be able to do it every single
time and um
it you know it can get really
frustrating if you get a couple battles
in a row
so let's see what we can do
that'll be good
all right so now we just have to work
over here um unfortunately
sort of the traffic jam
there's
just this is the only match that we have
on this side
we can just sort of work around it
since we do have our moves left
and that'll do it so
that's the way that works
it's a tough level and
it's just really important that you um
understand how the coloring candy works
and
use it to
open up as much space as you can um
if you haven't read it yet read our
guide for more tips and
if you have any questions leave a
comment there
we'll get back to you like the video if
you found it helpful thanks